[Music]
corn pudding what's that
what
are you trying to tell me that you've
never heard of corn pudding
she's never heard of corn pudding
it's a song you just started another
song
hey there i'm mark ellis and welcome to
a euphonius new episode of rt essentials
since the dawn of talkies movie musicals
have dominated hollywood from the wizard
of oz to singing in the rain and more
recently la la land and tick tick boom
one thing is for sure we love a world
that
spontaneously breaks into song and dance
even if that never happens in reality
except during a flash mob or what i just
performed today we'll explore how our
society's love for musicals translates
on the small screen i'd say the
explosion of melodious shows across all
networks and streamers sings for itself
in fact almost every series we'll be
discussing today premiered in the last
decade proof that the yearning for
tuneful content only gets louder with
time though not every show on this list
is technically a musical at least not in
the traditional sense they do all
contain classic musical numbers or are
centered around music and the industry
itself also for legal reasons we can't
play full-on songs from any of these
shows can i sing it you don't want me to
roger that but we'll do our best to get
your toes tapping with the sound of this
voice now without further ado these are
our selections for the best musical tv
shows glee
[Applause]
awesome hey where's the hate
not the point of glee club sue and
sliding in first is the smash hit glee
originally airing on fox in march of
2009 and running for six seasons 121
episodes the show was set at the
fictional william mckinley high school
where an optimistic teacher named will
shuster heads up the glee club known as
new directions not to be confused with
one direction who have sadly broken up
i'm still not over it couldn't you guys
have worked it out like i'm not that
upset but really zayn you're just gonna
bounce like that
sorry back to glee ambitious and
talented students find strength
acceptance and most relevantly their
voice within the glee club and also
enjoy a respite from the harsh realities
of life as mr shuster helps his students
in every way that he can and pursues the
collective goal of taking the group to
nationals he faces opposition from a
conniving cheerleading coach named sue
sylvester who tries to sabotage the club
at every turn well i know brittany
brittany because my name is also britney
spears
what what the hell is she talking about
my middle name is susan my last name is
pierce that makes me brittany s pierce
britney spears i've lived my entire life
in britney spears shadow i will never be
as talented or as famous
i hope you'll all respect that i want
glee club to remain a place where i
brittany s pierce can escape the torment
of britney spears the series was
conceived by ian brennan who based the
concept on his own high school
experiences in a choir brennan had
originally written glee as a
feature-length film but ryan murphy and
brad falchuk suggested that it be
produced as a television series instead
so the film concept was scrapped and the
script was rewritten for the tv format
at the time fox had one of the biggest
shows on the planet something called
american idol which is i guess still a
huge show but it moved to abc in 2018.
anyways fox was well aware of the demand
for music driven content and apparently
picked up the pilot for glee within
hours of receiving it the series
featured numerous covers of classic
songs sung by an ever expanding cast and
ranging from hits like teenage dream by
katy perry to somebody to love by queen
critics like entertainment weekly called
the show so good that it blasts past any
defenses you might put up against it and
that it will not stop until it wins you
over utterly
crazy ex-girlfriend if you want her go
for it
maybe i will hmm
maybe i will throw my saddle on that
philly yeah take her for a ride around
the paddock yeah oh yeah you're gonna
ride that new chair
men are disgusting yeah rachel bloom and
elene brosh mckenna wrote created and
directed the rom-com musical drama crazy
ex-girlfriend which premiered on the cw
in october of 2015. bloom also stars in
the lead role of rebecca bunch a
successful and driven new yorker who
seems to have it all the upscale
apartment the partnership at a
prestigious law firm but still she feels
like something's missing and after a
chance meeting with her former romantic
interest rebecca impulsively decides to
give up her life in new york and
relocate to west covina california over
the course of its four season run the
show penned
157 original songs averaging two to four
per episode like i mentioned in the
intro we love a world where characters
spontaneously break into song and dance
and bloom and mckenna took that idea and
ran with it or maybe i should say danced
with it most of the songs are sung by
protagonist rebecca or by character
she's directly interacting with and the
musical device is actually used to drive
the plot forward and often melodically
replaces necessary dialogue that would
otherwise just be conversational
wow
you look go wait a minute where's the
dress i bought you oh right yes i
donated that to the west covina middle
school drama department because only a
13 year old girl could fit into it what
makes crazy ex-girlfriend even more of a
standout is the juxtaposition between
the exuberant performances and the
serious recurring themes themes like
subjects and ideas not like theme songs
you get though this is a good time to
point out that the show featured an
entirely new theme song for each season
all of them were spectacular i might add
but what i meant is that crazy
ex-girlfriend portrays themes like
mental illness in ways that no other
show or musical ever has notably
psychological traumas and how they
influence relationships and
personalities there's this one 80s
inspired ballad called a diagnosis where
rebecca sings the words i'm aware mental
illness is stigmatized but the stigma is
worth it if i've realized who i meant to
be
absolutely brilliant all these elements
combined to make crazy ex-girlfriend a
critical success with the guardian
calling it wild ambitious and full of
powerful women not only defined by who
they love but how far they're willing to
go for it
empire
oh
do you remember this one
because i do
yeah i sent tapes from the inside back
and forth with you while you worked on
them out here
empire was created by lee daniels and
danny strong for fox it starred terence
howard as lucious lion hip hop artist
and ceo of empire entertainment line has
remained at the top unchallenged by his
underwings until a medical diagnosis
predicts he will be incapacitated in
three years and the power-hungry sharks
start to circle wyan is forced to decide
which of his three sons will take over
hakeem jamal or andre all the while the
situation gets even more complicated
when lyon's ex-wife reappears demanding
that lion compensated her for taking the
fall for the drug running that financed
his early career empire has been called
a mash-up between the lion and winter
and the godfather set in the world of
hip-hop music lee daniels made his
directorial debut at this show but had
directed several feature-length films
prior including shadowboxer the paperboy
the butler and of course precious which
earned him a best director and best
picture oscar nomination
hi grandma hi baby we're your
grandfather no sis
lucy
lucy
she playing you
excuse me we are in the middle of
planning
me you in the middle of getting your
gone
you too fake ass jackie yo kickbox it's
family business so although daniels was
well established in the movie business
he felt that his musical tastes were too
dated for a show like empire so he
consulted with timberland to help craft
the music for the series initially there
was some uncertainty about whether the
show had the potential to connect with a
wide audience but those ratings do not
lie empire's premiere ranked as fox's
highest rated debut in three years it
was also the first primetime broadcast
in the previous 23 years to see a
viewership increase week to week in its
first five episodes in its
2014-2015 season it surpassed the big
bang theory as the highest rated
scripted program and saw the highest
rated debut season finale since grey's
anatomy in 2005. empire ran for six
seasons 102 episodes received numerous
accolades and has been praised for being
audaciously honest on black issues and
credited for changing the look of ustv
galavan
there is a potion for reviving the dead
that i've been working on but i've been
missing one rare ingredient so it's
never been fully successful what is this
ingredient
i will climb any mountain battle any foe
slay any beast a gray hair from the
beard of a middle-aged man who is pure
of body
untouched by a woman
[Music]
rest in peace my friend i shall miss you
dan fogelman created and wrote gallivant
a fairy tale comedy that features the
music of award-winning composer alan
menken and the lyrics of glenn slater it
follows titure character gallivant a
dashing hero who embarks on a quest to
restore his happily ever after when he
loses made elena the love of his life to
king richard gallivant is well prepared
to use his many skills to win back and
avenge his beautiful lady but his
adventure gives rise to endless twists
turns and challenges similar to crazy
ex-girlfriend this show's characters
will suddenly burst into broadway-style
musical numbers several times in each
episode the plot is absolutely
ridiculous described as the bastard
child of monty python and the princess
bride by actress mallory janssen but
despite the show's whimsical tendencies
some of the featured tunes still manage
to tug at the old heartstrings one
example is the song if i could share my
life with you sung by the characters
chef vincenzo and gwyn though the song
maintains a lighthearted charm it's
surprisingly heavy in its message of
dreaming big in a small world and
learning to embrace the now the king is
having a secret meeting where i'm
deserve snacks and a light refreshment
as soon as the croaks of the frogs usher
in the raven's last call
it's like nine o'clock yeah nine o'clock
galavant was also known for frequent
cameos from well-known celebrities such
as ricky gervais and kylie minogue and
his recurring cast members that included
john stamos and are you sitting down
weird al yankovic yep weird al plays the
head monk of a group that has taken a
vow of singing if that isn't reason
enough to watch the show then i don't
know what to tell you gallivant ran for
two seasons 18 episodes and received
generally positive reviews with the
boston globe writing that if you're a
fan of musical theater then you just
might find some enjoyment in this cheery
eight episode miniseries and fun fact
the second season of galavant has a 100
perfect tomato meter score so i'd say
yeah there's a lot of musical theater
fans out there
the get down yeah why is that
it's what politicians should be asking
but who's got time for questions when
y'all skiing up on aspen bros get gun
shots to the head and all y'all swerving
us is aspen my mama was so lovely she
would have made your head spin level the
playing field y'all would see who would
really win and yeah i got anger
but i don't want to take me down cause
my mama taught me better and she holds
me up when i fall down
multi-faceted filmmaker boz lerman
teamed up with pulitzer winning
playwright stephen adley gurgis to
create the musical drama the get down
which premiered on netflix in august of
2016. the series is set in the 1970s
when new york was at the break of
bankruptcy and disco was dying out the
rise of hip-hop is told through the
lives art music and dance of a group of
young people in the south bronx in
addition to lerman and gorgeous the show
was produced by sean ryan nazir jones
better known by a stage name naz and
acclaimed costume designer catherine
martin who having won four academy
awards remains the most awarded
australian in oscar history lerman's
vision was ambitious and no expenses
were spared to make this show as
authentic as possible which is
particularly difficult when creating a
period piece y'all want to rumble like
it's the old days instead of riding
around in a flower jay you got one shot
get it on the humble make your battle a
dj rumble
hip-hop legends grandmaster flash curtis
blow nas and dj cool herc were deeply
involved in the show's development even
hosting a hip-hop boot camp to help
educate the younger actors flash worked
closely with a production designer
making sure the gear was true to the era
down to the mixers and turntables and
even how he'd hold his headphones sony
even opened up their entire vault so
that flash could comb through original
multitracks and pull out songs he wanted
to remix the music was the crucial
element of the storytelling much like
hip-hop was a crucial element of that
time and place unfortunately a show that
sets such a high bar comes at a high
price the get down was netflix's most
expensive series to date costing roughly
120 million dollars to produce which
surpassed the original budget of
7.5 million dollars it's just a few
pennies over its change you'll find in
the count the show was cancelled after
only 11 episodes but its legacy lives on
thanks to the supreme music vibrant cast
and thoughtful set design
we are lady parts
[Music]
stop stop
why are we suffering we sound profoundly
harsh assessment now you know what we
somewhere what's worse than hemorrhoids
you know what i think we sound great
boris johnson no we sound
on a cosmic level athlete's foot puberty
camel toe the play black lung vegan
cheese shut up taz we are lady parts is
a british sitcom that originally aired
on channel 4 in may of 2021 it's the
brainchild of nida mansour who created
wrote and directed the show it follows
amina hussein a geeky biochemical
engineering phd student who becomes the
lead guitarist of lady parts an
all-female muslim punk fan striving to
get a proper gig the fan's fierce front
woman sarah sees something in amina that
the other band members can't so sarah
offers to set amina up with potential
romantic matches if she agrees to join
the band and now amina finds herself
torn between her straightways university
friends and the edgy members of the band
manzor has said that this series is
somewhat autobiographical having grown
up in a pakistani muslim family and
forfeited the path that was expected of
her becoming a human rights lawyer to
pursue a career in the arts specifically
filmmaking you you have done it
brilliantly babe you've got the family
unit and the art both coexisting in
happy symbiosis
right
daughter
i think we should depart from this place
before we choke on the fumes of this
toxic masculinity okay bye papa my uncle
bye baby manzor is inspired by women she
came across at various art collectives
and musicians who are expressing the
fullness of their identities she wanted
to create a show that highlighted such
personalities and felt that up until
this point there hadn't been proper
representation of muslim women in
television stating that muslim women on
tv were mostly portrayed as oppressed
and lacking agency and without joy and
humor i think we can all agree that
mansour accomplished exactly what she
set out to do because this show has
managed to pack more humor into its
first and so far only season that most
shows will in their entire lifespan so
it's not too surprising that we our lady
parts boast a 100 tomato meter score and
that critics like usa today have called
the show pithy and outrageously funny
also word on the street is that season
two is on the way
zoe's extraordinary playlist should we
grab arms and jump up and down right now
i think we should
i just remembered these walls are
see-through
next up is the dramedy zoe's
extraordinary playlist which originally
aired on nbc jane levy stars as zoe
clark a whip smart computer coder who
after an unusual event magically begins
to hear people's innermost wants and
desires through popular songs okay i
know unusual event is super vague
basically an earthquake occurs while
she's getting an mri and an expansive
playlist of songs on file are downloaded
into her brain it happens all the time i
don't even know why i had to explain it
to you anyways strangers friends
co-workers and family members are now
unknowingly singing their feelings just
to zoe who thinks she's losing her mind
after some guidance from her dj neighbor
mo and a breakthrough with her ailing
father zoe comes to terms with her
condition and realizes it just might be
a wonderful gift after all you are
punky brewster
garbage oh my god of course you are now
it goes without saying that you can't
name your show zoey's extraordinary
playlist and not feature some straight
up jams or as the cool kids like to call
them bangers and yes this show is banger
packed with incredible performances of
cover songs like taylor swift's shake it
off and tears for fears mad world well
it's actually cast member john clarence
stewart portraying simon singing gary
jules's version of tears for fears mad
world yes that's mad confusing but the
important thing to note here is that
stuart levy and the rest of the main
cast actually do all of their own
singing and dancing and that's nothing
short of extraordinary the series ran
for two seasons 26 episodes but was
ultimately cancelled by nbc due to
falling ratings but that didn't stop the
show from developing a cult following
and being hailed by critics as an
ambitious concept brimming with joy and
compassion that hits the right notes
schmingadoon this basket is going to
henry for two dollars and two bits going
once
going twice hold on there mr mayor
twenty dollars
so to the newcomer mr skinner there for
twenty dollars hello schmegadoon
sorry not you i'm not calling you ish
mega dune i don't really even know what
it's megadude means oh wait it's a play
on the title the 1954 classic brigadoon
which starred at gene kelly but you'd
already know that if you're a musical
aficionado like schmigadoon creators
cinco paul and ken dario in fact this
entire series is a parody of and an
homage to the musicals of the 40s and
50s it follows backpacking couple
melissa and josh who get trapped in
shmiga dune a magical town filled with
singing and dancing townspeople the two
learned that they can't leave without
finding true love which they thought
they had already had
what
we can't leave it's like magic we're in
an actual musical please god no the
magnificent cast includes comedy legends
like keegan michael key cecily strong
and fred armisen and the series was
produced and directed by barry
sonnenfeld the man behind the adams
family and the men in black trilogy
cinco paul actually wrote all of the
original songs for the series which adds
up to roughly two dozen spread over only
six half-hour episodes paul attributes
his musical prowess to his upbringing
having grown up listening to his
mother's broadway cast recordings and
having played piano for musicals while
he was an undergraduate at yale the new
york times perfectly penned this review
of the show and its main characters the
josh's of the world are unlikely to ever
warm to shmigadoon but to my fellow
melissas dust off your character's shoes
our time is now
high school musical the musical the
series this is the moment when the
creative team begins to give the show
over to the cast which is strangely
emotional actually but miss jen says
that's a life in the arts well that and
almost constant unemployment
disney plus brings us high school
musical the musical the series a
mockumentary drama created by tim
fetterly and based on you guessed it the
high school musical film series set at a
fictionalized version of east high
school where the original movie was
filmed the series introduces members of
the drama club and their faculty
advisors as they perfect their produced
musicals and work toward the
nerve-wracking opening night romances
blossom friendships are pushed to their
limits rivalries ensue and lives are
forever changed as these students
discover the transformative power that
only high school theater can provide
disney started developing the series way
back in 2017 approaching federally who
drafted a pilot utilizing the
documentary-style device that has risen
in popularity thanks to films like this
is spinal tap and documentary now
is that really her phone hold it to your
ear like a seashell
you'll hear echoes of v-hudge crushing
the b-flat on when there was me in here
or you can let me disinfect it first
in 2018 disney officially gave the
production a serious order for a
10-episode first season and the rest was
hip shaking history the soundtrack for
the series includes new songs and
renditions of songs from the original
high school musical film with cast
member and pop sensation olivia rodrigo
pending the song all i want and
co-writing just for a moment with joshua
bassett high school musical the musical
the series is not just a fun title to
say it's received mostly rave reviews
with npr writing that this show will hit
the spot for those over and under 12 who
enjoyed the earnest silly pleasantness
of high school musical additionally
critics have praised and highlighted the
cast performances notably rodrigo and
bassett season three is expected to be
released this year
girls five eva look who's he's timing
hey i hear you have a big performance
tonight oh yeah we do you want to say
i'm super excited for you you're gonna
do great oh thank you honey bunny
so have a great show and congratulations
to all cause kev from the boys next door
thinks you're too pretty for college
this has a cameo she bought a cameo from
her husband to make us think he's
facetiming good so thanks for being a
fan stranger oh wow okay and last but
certainly not least is girls five eva
created by meredith scardino who's
written for several tv comedies
including the unbreakable kimmy schmidt
and mr mayer this series centers around
a one hit wonder girl group from the
1990s who reunite after a song of theirs
gets sampled by an up-and-coming rapper
and they suddenly have another shot at
stardom only thing is they now have to
balance spouses kids jobs debt aging
parents and naturally
shoulder pain scardino wrote the lyrics
for most of the original songs featured
in girls 5 eva with the help of
executive producer jeff richmond who
also composed the music for the mean
girls musical and happens to be married
to one of the funniest people on the
planet who also happened to executive
produce this show and also happens to
play dolly parton in the character
dawn's imagination
yes it's tina fey who else are you in
stomp we're a girl group ah well your
knee has absorbed years of sustained
damage you need a knee replacement
you can get a second opinion but it will
signal to me that you don't trust a
female doctor
additionally lead actress sarah barayas
who plays dawn also contributed to some
of the songs taking influence from the
music of nsync destiny's child and abba
scardino received an emmy nomination for
outstanding writing for a comedy series
and girls 5 ever has been hailed as an
excessively absurdist show packed with
truly funny parody songs and
performances that rival the best on air
and there you have it our selections for
the best musical tv shows as always we
couldn't cover every series that fits
the bill but there's plenty more
episodes of rt essentials coming your
way so i'm sure we'll get there soon
thanks again for tuning in i'm mark
ellis and this quote goes out to all you
aspiring music-minded artists out there
follow every rainbow till you find your
dream
[Music]